now take an ordinary dog and train it to
do extraordinary things do you get a
genius
this is canine camp training an elite
corps of super dogs for special jobs as
doorman handyman and rescue worker in an
emergency they're trained to nose punch
a 911 yes good boy
it's dog bootcamp without the boot one
day these recruits will become helping
companions to people with disabilities
but first through positive reinforcement
they must learn to think for themselves
as canine assistants founder Jennifer
Arnold our dogs have to love what
they're doing because we don't punish
them when they don't do it so fear is
not a reason for them to comply and when
they leave us and they go home with
their recipient when the recipient says
will you pick this up for me well I mean
it's all up to the dog Jennifer is
creating super dogs for the first year
and a half of their lives these dogs go
through rigorous conditioning
stimulating the brain and body in ways
some scientists say make them better
learners she starts him young at three
days old new born Olympics upside down a
cold towel
and pause stimulation at this early
stage dog brain cells and neural
connections between them strengthen and
multiply some neurologists say these
brain teasing exercises enhance the
process and reduce stress and fear later
on when the intense training begins a
few weeks later
welcome to the puppy room the window for
hardwired learning takes place before 16
weeks during these critical first months
just about everything they learn yes
good job will be permanently stored in
their bodies and minds excellence the
puppy room throws them into situations
they'll encounter in their new homes so
nothing will faze them they become
familiar with lights get their light yes
good light good job other household pets
even themselves
[Music]
and then the world beyond each puppy
goes on a personalized guided tour of
the human environment look at that good
girl ready
let's go baby it's critical that young
puppies get out to the grocery store to
you know ride the train to go to the
airport
if buses do all those things that they
may do in their adult careers
oh what's that